puisqu'à maintenant la situation est
sous contrôle
non les suit de très près ce que les
gens peuvent faire pour nous aider le
plus c'est de respecter les consignes
ils ont comparé la courbe du québec aux
coupes des autres m'ont fourni encore
dans le play le petit gars mais déjà il
je veux pas parler tout à l'avant ce
qu'on remarque c'est en train de monter
un peu moins vite avec nous vous le
connaissez bien maintenant le docteur
horacio arruda directeur national de la
santé publique à québec
docteur arruda bonsoir à vous bonsoir
alors est ce que parce qu'aujourd'hui on
sentait non pas bon ben ça y est tout
est fini mais on sentait qu quand même
une lueur d'optimiste dans la mesure où
vous avez dit que la courbe québécois
vous aimez ce que vous voyez dans
l'augmentation des cas là c'est pas trop
drastiques
non mais y louer c'est vrai je suis
satisfait de voir ce qu'on voit et de
mais je pense qu'il n'y a pas un message
à dire faut pas marcher
ok premièrement on va augmenter la
quantité de tests de façon significative
au québec notamment tester d'autres
sites de personnes ce qui va
probablement mener une augmentation
comme tel et à ceux ci aux facteurs de
deux tests mais on suit la situation le
nouveau ministère de la santé avec nos
experts scientifiques ont regardé
projection qu'on avait on regarde
comment ça se fait je pense que faut
comprendre que les mesures qu'on a mise
en place doivent pour avoir leur effet
le c'est à peu près entre 10 à 12 jours
dont il est trop tôt à mon avis pour
mesurer mais ce qui est important aussi
c'est comme un médicament faut prendre
la bonne dose puis faut le prendre le
nombre de jours que nécessaire il faut
pas lâcher
bon à l'arche et maintenant ça c'est une
erreur dramatique ça s'en remettrait à
l'exclu plus haut puis par contre il
faut analyser chacune des situations
des fois on va voir des situations à des
endroits là on a l'impression que ça
vaut petit puchot ailleurs qu'ailleurs
au québec c'est plus en région c'est
plusieurs villes la station vont varier
dans le temps mais ça se pousse à se
regarder au niveau régional c'est
regarder nouveau nationale pour prendre
des décisions éclairées et à la question
fondamentale c'est est ce que le québec
et le canada mais le québec vous occuper
du québec va éviter
exemple de l'italie il est trop tôt pour
le dire dites vous mais dans les fêtes
vous savez le moi aussi c'est que on ne
fait d des ordonnances des gens une
bonne proportion de la population l'a
établi on a beaucoup voulu convaincre
qu'on va rester dans le mode convaincre
parce que on veut pas contre elle
nécessairement mais une bonne réponse la
population message du quai des secteurs
qui ont pas nécessairement répondu ou
une catégorie darche qui fait parce
qu'on a des comme conseil pour voir ça
compte peuvent continuer à bombarder
je pense que moi j'aime mieux un danse
expression là être optimiste mais
surtout à être pessimiste par rapport
aux actions et donc de grâce
on a encore savez là si on frappe fort
tout le monde ensemble tôt maintenant on
veut capable d'abaisser d'éviter on à
faire des choix effroyable comme en
italie je voudrais pas être dans une
telle y est pour être clair docteur
arruda
on peut encore éviter le scénario
italienne c'est ce qu'on pense
on fait tout pour ça je tiens à vous
dire on fait tout pour ça on a appris
des pays qui ont bien performé on appris
des pays qui ont moins bien performé
puis c'est ce qu'on fait on veut pas à
voir l'italie des c'est là qu'on a
france on veut et à mesure que le
système de soins par l'apathie ce mandat
courbe permettent à tout le monde d'être
était donc c'est pour ça que vous êtes
même si l'augmentation paraît pas
gigantesque au québec là ne baissons pas
les bras et surtout le message c'est pas
dire bon verre ressortons dehors tout va
bien non surtout pas surtout pas surtout
pas j'insiste là dessus
as avec le temps de ressortir kerleau
plus de danger ou qu'on veut remonter un
peu l'activité
on va vous dire nommé pensez pas parce
que la courbe abbès où avoir infléchir
que c'est le temps de marcher il ya on
va vous faire la prescription très bien
il ya beaucoup de parents qui nous
écoutent avec des enfants la maison
évidemment c'est une nouvelle vie depuis
lundi le premier ministre a dit tout à
l'heure
primaire secondaire fin mars aussi
illusoire de penser que le saas relevé
dans votre esprit est ce que l'année
scolaire
là je parle du primaire et du secondaire
je ne parle pas du cégep et l'université
dans votre esprit ce que l'année
pratiquement terminé écoutez je sais
difficile puis je pense que la prudence
deux premiers men et c'est
adéquat parce que les prochains jours et
semaines vont être majeur dans la
décision
quand on va savoir qu'on peut pas
réouvrir par exemple début mais parce
que c'est ce qu'on pense qui pourrait
potentiellement arriver tout
dépendamment comment le virus va
circuler
puis comment la saisonnalité vont venir
on riait revue réévaluera ça sert à rien
masqué c'est clair maintenant par contre
pour que les gens puissent organiser
c'est que faut pas penser qu 39 ces
écoles vont rouvrir très bien c'est
clair
l'âge des malades ça revient beaucoup on
a énormément de questions là dessus
parce que les gens attendent toutes
sortes de choses à d'autres pays
on a préparé un tableau je crois qu'on a
l'âge des malades pour le québec
alors quel est l'état de la situation on
voit moins de deux ans il ya eu trois
cas positifs 2 à 5 ans 1,5 à 17 8 13 18
à 30 ans et etc
on peut être testé positif avoir deux en
cinq ans il n'a pas développé la maladie
a doctor who est très peu symptomatiques
dans le fond c'est ça qu'il faut voir le
faut comprendre aussi que c'est excessif
d'ici là actuellement de comparer les
chiffres de payer à l'autre parce que la
quantité de tests des gens font si les
gens font beaucoup beaucoup tests que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens peu symptômes
être c'est que le retour de mortalité va
avoir l'air plus bas vous avez sonics
malheureusement après certains mois en
fonction des données des études
sérologique la comparaison des routes en
mesure de comparer les taux donc ce que
je vais vous dire je pense
qu'actuellement le poids fils qu'on a au
québec correspond à ce qu'on s'attendait
puis c'est normal qu'en début quand on a
moins de tests conteste des personnes
n'est plus malade donc on va augmenter
la l'urd sévérité de la maladie mais sa
voix sera stabilisée à mesure qu'on va
faire beaucoup beaucoup de tests qu'on
va avoir une plus grande quantité de
population c'est très difficile de
comparer d'un pays à l'autre sans
prendre en considération ces facteurs là
lol ou son rang 10 ans la courbe sont
rendus à la fin nous on n'est même pas
encore dans le pic et on n'est même pas
encore dans la grande accélération et
mais on rappelle pour les gens parce que
c'est important puisqu'une bonne
nouvelle depuis le début ce faux pas la
perte de vue les enfants même s'ils sont
porteurs une des raisons pourquoi on a
fermé les écoles ne
blop pas une maladie grave de façon très
générale
exactement les enfants sont porteurs ou
peuvent mais par contre ils peuvent
ensemble lettre fait plus ses enfants on
retourne dans la famille retourne dans
les milieux on voit les grands parents
c'est là que des risques importants ceux
possédant les familles les écoles dr
arruda je profite de votre passage ici
pour n'apprécie d'ailleurs vous êtes
occupés on le sait beaucoup de gens se
demandent quand vous dites aux gens
restés à la maison par exemple marie
lortie nous demander ce que c'est
sécuritaire de laisser les enfants jouer
dans les aires de jeux au parc va
écouter comme je vous le dis là dans les
fêtes c'est que les enfants peuvent
sortir prendre l'air à l'extérieur ce
qui serait problématique c'est tous les
enfants du quartier soit dans le même
jeu canada d'inquiéter symptômes
kimouche tout ce que les enfants se
contaminent qu'on est en or la foulée
mais je suppose vous comprenez le
principe le principe c'est éviter les
rassemblements de personnes
ok éviter d'être en contact trop près
avec les personnes donc je pense qu'il
faut pas non plus confiné les gens
complètement particulièrement tendu pas
de circulation locale puis sans devoir
mais elle est dans la cour à l'extérieur
pour la fin à leur rassemblement faut
pas que tout les gardiennes se mettent
ensemble avec les enfants a même place
parce qu'on sait pas si sa folle est en
contact avec quelqu'un dont la densité
dans le fond il les fêtera le physique
c'est le rapprochement physique mais
docteur vous ne prescrivent et pas de
rester à la maison parce que vous l'avez
dit hier démarche dans le bois des
marches sur la rue avec une bonne
distance même si on est avec notre
enfant c'est bien là les gens peuvent ne
n'ont pas besoin de sa cabane et oui
effectivement puisque vous me permettez
on donnera par contre la circulation
intensive ici qu'on peut plus avoir six
en or tel plat soit elle place ça se
peut qu'à ce moment-là tout dépendamment
de où on va être rendu qu'on veut dire
aux gens de se confiner
mais les gens ont interprété je vous
donne un exemple c'est plus dangereux
que trois familles se rassemblent
ensemble pour un fai d'anniversaire
l'honneur
enfin à l'intérieur que d'aller à
l'extérieur où ils la distanciation et
c'est la majorité des cas qui ont été
transmis en chine se sont faites en à
l'extérieur ça puis en milieu de soins
ça s'est fait quand les gens se sont
regroupés à l'intérieur des maisons des
soupers la gastronomique entre nous les
rassemblements de famille n'est fait on
vous les ferez tarte avec un plus grand
cadeau puis on reportera sa préparer
testez vos recettes si vous voulez là
mais fait pas le rapport avec des
personnes de l'extérieur de chez vous
jojo reparler plus tard de vos recettes
leur vache folle et les questions du
public mais il ya vos tartes aux lettres
là qui ont fait sourire beaucoup de
monde
docteur combien de temps ça reste sur
les surfaces à revient ça revient ça
revient parce que j'ai évidemment
l'obsession de toucher quelqu'un qui
aurait touché une surface avant nous oui
pour comprendre ce virus là il peut pas
vivre c'est pas de liquide ou est ce
qu'on appelle alors que tous vont
cracher des gouttelettes de sécrétions
nasales et cetera cannes on est sur un
tissu qui pour eux l'homme était sa
serein
scott tawel puis j'allais voir
rapidement le réseau à mourir parce que
le tout ce qui est autour du virus qu'il
fermait le sourire est absorbée d'un
papier si vous êtes sur des surfaces qui
sont hyper liste des métaux le traître
lice mais la gouttelette avant comme
pearl et autres sauts doivent rester
plus longtemps sur des vêtements etc
son travail dans le domaine de la santé
sont étant content qu'on enlève notre
cerveau puis on ne transporte pas la
maison mais ça survivra pas si longtemps
que ça parce que c'est pour eux comme
tel par contre sur les objets sur la
mélamine ou sur particulièrement métal
très lucide et stable ça peut aller à
quelques jours jusqu'à quatre jours mais
si vous vous lavez ces raisons on a
régulièrement fait qu'après ça vous
lavez vos mains vous l'être après pas
donc par exemple dans les fruits les
légumes et je me pose la question mais
vous l'avez votre fruit
vous l'avez votre légumes à l'opus avons
là vous faire manger les boîtes les
cartons d'épicerie mundo là c'est pas
nécessairement contaminés mais si vous
avez pas vous toucher à ça vous enlevez
contenu que tu à l'intérieur vous vous
lavez les mains quand vous serez pas
contaminer le carton va absorber le
liquide qui vient avec le virus de
questions avant de vous laisser dr
arruda
qu'est ce qui va arriver avant d'après
vous un médicament
une fois qu'on est malade ou un vaccin
pour prévenir de l'attraper on pourrait
faire un auto mais moi je pense qu'un
met un médicament va probablement
arriver avant un vaccin parce qu'il ya
des grandes recherches en antiviraux
comment être fait mais ça pourrait être
un vaccin aussi si les activités sont
pas adéquats mais ya énormément de
recherches qui fait actuellement la
couleur et et bex que j'aimerais vous
couvrez la glace on a beaucoup parlé
est ce que ça marche ça marche parce que
les gens doivent où devraient se ruer ou
pas là non parce que je fais au dire
même notre ainsi nationale d'évaluation
centers y en a qui ne pourra marcher
dans certaines conditions mais c'est pas
dès maintenant mirap il faut continuer à
faire des recherches avec d'autres
antiviraux pour vaccins dont 4 euros qui
n'ont voilà réservé à certaines
situations des indications battu clame
de grâce commencez pas à prendre
d'accord keane qui est un anti malaria
et cd rom ou d'aller en chercher parce
que c'est pas la solution miracle mais
on va utiliser les médicaments qu en
regardant ce qui est le plus apte ou
dette
il faut pas faire de nuire aux gens en
prenant les mauvais médicament et donc
on va regarder ça de très très près très
bien docteur arruda merci bonvaux
tartelettes là en deux secondes c'est
quoi ça c'est comme une quiche ou quoi
maintenant c'est comme une pâte
feuilletée avec une crème pâtissière
ceux de suttons caramélise au four ça
vient de la région de belém qui est une
région de lisbonne pas loin ça couvre à
ces dessins ont inventé cette recette là
pour être capable de servir est
subventionnée de l'argent volé pour les
pauvres là la classique est caché et
recettes classiques à belém moi j'ai pas
une recette familiale parce que mes
parents vient des açores pas du portugal
mais je tendrais processus vous et c'est
des différentes recettes que j'ai vu
dans différents livres et quand j'aurai
trouvé la bonne jauge à les isoler très
bien docteur arruda prenez un peu de
repos quand même aussi parce qu'on veut
vous garder longtemps et puis on suit ce
soin de moi très loin de moi j'ai des
back up qui prenait soin de vous oui
traversant sa solidairement semble on
est capable puis heureusement que les
rythmes et aux réseaux regarder je vous
parle
chouette strass de vous pour communiquer
entre eux ils ont mutilé le web de façon
très intéressant tefana 6 à lui on sera
par merci docteur hugo revoir au revoir